How are you? It
's the opening of Vibria Fantasy, which has surpassed 5 million copies in the series
.
I can't choose the means to become a librarian with sound.
A 5-year-old girl, mine,
is a world without goods.
Mine struggles to make things by involving her family and surroundings, and is
finally caught in the library where the goods are displayed.
[Music]
And there was a new encounter, and finally
I started printing using metal type
. Mine, who became three blue, secretly swirled a plot in a part of Shingen,
and the crisis was one after another.  Imminent
[Music]
A mysterious person who suddenly appeared
I can't choose the means to become a librarian with a book on Heredia.
Temiro
Huang
Zen